[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour le 7-8 week-end actualité
idées de sorties pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 6 mai
depuis la fin de la présidentielle les
partis politiques sont tournés désormais
vers les élections législatives le
scrutin se teint les 12 et 19 juin et on
commence à y voir plus clair dans l'es12
circonscription des yvelines avec
l'officialisation et des premières
candidatures le point au début de cette
émission mardi 10 mai c'est la journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions à
cette occasion csm sky organise sa
journée hop ce dimanche à montigny le
bretonneux un événement dommages et de
partage nous en parlons avec mes acmad
kangourou président du collectif qui est
notre invité et puis comme tous les
vendredis nos idées de sorties pour les
deux prochains week-ends dans le
département ce sera dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et comme d'habitude bixente mayence anti
stepan vous livrera sa sélection des
idées de sorties bonjour bixente genre
grégory bon pour certains yvelinois il
ya le moral dans les chaussettes on peut
le dire avec la fin des vacances de
printemps qui approche qu'avez vous à
leur proposer pour leur redonner le
sourire aujourd'hui du cinéma des
visites de musées quand même comme il
fait beau du vélo aussi grégory cette
semaine plus ce sera tout à l'heure dans
le 7-8 week-end
mais je me tourne d'abord vers nicolas
landry bonjour bonsoir et autres
journalistes de la rédaction de tv 78
qui va nous parler des élections
législatives on est désormais à un peu
plus d'un mois de ce scrutin qui est
prévu les 12 et 19 juin avec des
investitures et et candidature qui
commence à être annoncés c'est le cas
dans l'es12 circonscription des yvelines
fait nous déjà un état des lieux sur la
situation actuelle et les députés
sortants quel sac et qui sont-ils et
bien souvenez-vous grégory en 2017 la
vague en marche avait embouti 11
circonscriptions sur 12 seule la 8e
avait résisté avec la droite qui s'était
maintenu avec le député les républicains
michel vial et puis en 2020 à l'occasion
d'une élection législative partielle
dans la 12e circonscription le candidat
des républicains philippe benassaya
remporté le scrutin depuis la droite
détient deux sièges et donc la
république en marche détient 10 sièges
dans les yvelines et on voit quelques
uns voilà des visages les mêmes les 12
visages des députés des douze
circonscription des yvelines est ce que
parmi ces douze députés sortants on sait
déjà si certains vont se relancer dans
la campagne alors grégory à l'heure
actuelle c'est à dire 16 heures vendredi
il n'y a aucune incertitude et des
annonces pas venir ce week-end les
candidatures de la majorité
présidentielle dans les yvelines n'ont
pas encore été officialisée mais ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que jean noël
barrot et bruno myle yens pour le modem
devrait tenter de briguer un second
mandat dans la deuxième et neuvième
circonscription tout comme didier
baichère béatrice pions marie lebey
qu'elle brûle privé natalia pouces iref
et aurore bergé donc de nombreux députés
yves binois qui vont briller tenter de
briguer un second mandat
ensuite concernant la 7e circonscription
et la 12e michel devaux couleurs et
florence granger ne vont pas se
représenter et d'après certaines
informations qui circulent nadia qui est
l'actuel ministre délégué de la ville
devrait se présenter dans la 7e
circonscription
et puis concernant la 12e le maire de
poissy car le livre pourrait représenter
le mouvement horizons dans la deuxième
compris une grande majorité des députés
sortants qui vont briguer un nouveau
mandat et ce qu'il ya aussi de nouveaux
candidats qui sont annoncées qui se sont
déclarés pour cette campagne première
formation politique à avoir officialisé
et bien les candidats c'est les
républicains et lui dit regardez les
candidats vont s'afficher donc des
candidats qui partent sous la bannière
union de la droite et du centre donc
nous retrouvons des élus départementaux
et régionaux à l'image de olivier de la
sphère politique vide au cours lefebvre
bertrand coq à alexandra du blanche ou
encore un cabri
on voit aussi que il ya une personnalité
que qui est connu dans les médias parce
qu'il participe à des émissions de télé
de débat c'est charles qu'on cynique est
avocat donc qui est entré gay mais
parachuté mais il assume totalement ce
parachutage et donc la stratégie des
républicains on le voit c'est mettre des
personnalités qui sont reconnus
localement pour tenter de gagner le
maximum de sièges
autres officialisation c'est du côté de
reconquête dans les yvelines le
mouvement politique d'eric zemmour on
verra bien des candidats dans l'ensemble
des circonscriptions et on va les voir
s'afficher il ya laurence trochut dans
la première circonscription des yvelines
donc laurence trop chic est connue parce
que si une ex membre des républicains
elle a été à la tête du mouvement sens
commun et puis elle a mené le combat
contre le mariage pour tous si on
regarde aussi les autres personnalités
on connaît nous christophe le hot
puisqu'on l'a suivi dans plusieurs
scrutins il représentait le
rassemblement national ou encore
philippe chevrier 1 figure dans la 10e
circonscription de l'extrême droite donc
si je vous suis on voit qu'il ya douze
candidats pour reconquête dans les
yvelines c'est à dire qui aura pas de
d'alliance entre le rassemblement
national et et reconquête bah en fait
grégory le président fédéral du parti de
marine le pen laurent bourrin m'a
confirmé au téléphone cette semaine qui
aurait bien douze candidats du
rassemblement national dans les yvelines
des candidatures qui seront présentés et
officialisée le 17 et 18 mai au
lendemain de la fin des dépôts des
candidatures en préfecture on va
terminer avec la gauche c'est confirmé
cette nuit c'était confirmé la nuit
dernière dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi le ps parti socialiste partira
avec l'union de la gauche donc composé
de la france insoumise qui veut dire
leader parti leader dans cette union
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste comment ça va s'organiser
dans les yvelines du coup alors déjà
première chose le nom des candidats
seront connus
ce week-end c'est à dire qu'on connaîtra
l'ensemble des candidats partout en
france et notamment du coup dans les
yvelines à l'heure où je vous parle
encore une fois voici la distribution
des circonscriptions yvelinoise en
fonction des mouvements politiques on le
voit sur cette carte finalement c'est la
france insoumission à le maximum de
circonscription avec une présence dans
la une la d3 à l'a4 l'a5 et l'a6 l'a9
l'a10 est la 11e europe ecologie les
verts aura deux candidats dans la 2e
circonscription et dans la 12e
circonscription
le parti socialiste aura la 7e
circonscription la 7e circonscription
c'est la circonscription historiques ou
v situé conflans sainte honorine
historique pourquoi pour le parti
socialiste parce que c'est là où michel
rocard a été élu député et enfin la 8e
circonscription sera donnée devrait être
donnée à un candidat de génération point
génération poser est ce qu'on connaît
très bien à saint quentin en yvelines
parce que c'est benoît hamon qui a lancé
ce mouvement suite à sa défaite avec le
parti socialiste en 2010 elle ses
représentants et bien sûr le maire de
trappes ali rabais merci nicolas pour
toutes ces précisions on devrait avoir
plus d'offices ya lisation dans les
prochains jours mais en tout cas voici
le premier état des lieux qu'on pouvait
vous faire a maintenant un peu plus d'un
mois de ce scrutin des élections
législatives qui va arriver en engageant
dans les yvelines et aussi partout en
france merci pour ce point retour à
présent sur les autres actualités qui
ont marqué la semaine dans le
département des yvelines où vous résume
le tout bien sûr en 78
[Musique]
le gymnase de la fraternité de la
verrière a accueilli le premier tournoi
à dos des sites et fantastique des
yvelines co-organisé par le réalisateur
verrier roanne à dire yul un entre jeu
vidéo et balle au prisonnier ado est un
sport d'équipé en réalité augmentée
venus du japon les communes des yvelines
engagées contre les noyades première
cause de mortalité par accidents chez
les moins de 25 ans plusieurs stages de
natation étaient proposés pendant les
vacances de printemps et notamment à
saint cyr l'école une nouvelle vie pour
l'ancien relais de poste de joueur pour
chartrain le gué relais est désormais un
espace de coworking 500 m² d'espacés
aménagés qui héberge déjà une dizaine de
coworkers coût total de la rénovation
2,5 millions d'euros l'ancien maire de
mantes-la-jolie agressé raphaël cogné a
été frappé par trois hommes qui ont vidé
également sur lui le contenu d'un
extincteur des faits qui se sont
produits dans le quartier du val fourré
touchés par des épisodes de violences
cette semaine et ce en plein contexte de
l'élection municipale partielle des 15
et 22 mai pour laquelle raphaël cognait
candidats il a porté plainte et reçu de
nombreux soutiens dans celui du préfet
des yvelines jean jacques brot qui a
condamné cette agression et puis un
tournoi international de parra tennis de
table a démarré jeudi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
près de 400 points gist de l'élite
mondiale sont de la partie avec
plusieurs médaillés des derniers jeux
paralympiques de tokyo
[Musique]
ce sera l'une des dates à retenir la
semaine prochaine mardi prochain c'est
la journée nationale de la mémoire de la
traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions depuis 2006 elle a lieu tous
les 10 mai en france à saint quentin en
yvelines vous le voyez l événement sera
commémorée par une journée aube ce
dimanche en événements de partage des
changes qui se déroulera de 11h à 18h au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin c'est
à montigny le bretonneux s est organisé
par votre collectif mais acmat mangou
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
le président de cme csm sky qui est le
collectif pour la semaine de la mémoire
de l esclavage à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette journée
du 10 mai si on peut revenir déjà sur
sur ses objectifs on précise qu'elle a
été instauré par un décret est de mars
2006 et le but de cette journée bien sûr
c'est de se souvenir mais aussi
peut-être d'éduquer les futures
générations sur le sujet et de quelle
génération mais ce taux de partager
cette année - pour que cette opération
soit concerné par l'événement c'est une
date importante et il ya une autre date
importante d'ailleurs c'est le 10 mai
2001 c'est la loi taubira reconnu
officiellement la la traite négrière et
l'esclavagé
oui justement de l'inspection du 10 mai
comme journée de commémoration c'est la
suite de cette nouvelle puisque c'était
prévu qu'on aurait une journée pour
commencer comme les moyens et les des
traits est venue dix on souhaite à la
commission qui avec instaurée par la loi
qui a travaillé à proposer cette journée
comme toujours les commémorations en
france métropolitaine à côté de journée
dix ans de condamnation d'un des autres
et donc il ya lieu en france
métropolitaine tous les 10 mai au niveau
local le collectif pour la semaine de la
mémoire de l'esclavagé saint quentin en
yvelines a été créé en 2011 quelles sont
les actions c'est qu'il ya chaque chaque
année une semaine qui est organisé par
par votre collectif wickham il ya une
semaine et l'idée c'était de faire 17 17
qui était un événement de cette occasion
de besoin disons de d'être présent dans
plusieurs villes de là nos nations donc
chacun y ont essayé de couvrir trois
quatre villes et au fait de confier de
conférence il ya deux rencontres les
écoles il y a
une projection débat et plus et des
journées disons plus populaires dommage
ils ont comme celle qu'on va faire le
rythme donc cette année on a une version
un peu réduite parce qu'on sort les deux
années d'interruption avec qu'ovide donc
on a voulu en fait ne pas trop charger
la barque pas sont eux pas sûr qu'on
arrive et réduisons à cette période ci
avec un état de pandémie qui permettrait
de faire
c'est vrai qu'on n'y pense pas la
pandémie a aussi rendues difficiles
toutes les phases de commémoration
exactement ses valises pendant les deux
ans et reste injuste à des échanges pas
aux modes de consommation plutôt virtuel
est donc coincé de la reprise après deux
années d'interruption alors la reprise à
saint quentin avec cette journée au
point je le disais ce dimanche 8 mai de
11h à 18h c'est au centre sportif pierre
de coubertin à montigny le bretonneux
alors ce qui est annoncé c'est un
événement dommage de partage des changes
ça rendez-vous de sensibilisation il ya
quand même une volonté que ce soit
festif tout de même bien une volonté de
10 on s'assoit convivial pas forcément
festif mais conviviale
disons c'est on a pensé que c'est
l'occasion de rendre hommage à tous ceux
qui ont oeuvré pour tous ceux qui ont
lutté contre à la fois à la traite et
l'esclavagé plus tard contre les
séquelles donc on a voulu sonner pour
leur rendre hommage et à cette occasion
ses ingénieurs des expositions qu'on
présente mais c'est aussi disons un des
moments de partage autour de cette
mémoire donc on a disons des repas au
pouvoir à se retrouver et discuter et on
a un marché qui permet de découvrir des
ils ont des créations ou des
centres de création de produits disons
tropicaux de façon générale et on a
aussi ce sera le tropical markets et il
ya aussi la fraude autour qui est
proposé autour
d'iso
l'événement phare de cette année parce
qu'on évolue en fait
un voyage sur les traces en fait de la
des traditions de la culture de
l'histoire des bisons des
afrodescendants à face en général
d'accord c'est un tour qui a voyagé par
en fait de l'afrique
pour les traces disons de la traite mais
c'est ce que ces pays sont devenus en
visite quelques pays à travers des
stands présentant fait des sites de
mémoire c'était historique dans des
sites touristiques pour voir un père si
les gens ils vont aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'ils n'arriveront trouver on part
aussi sur les amériques à ibb et on va
aussi aussi sociale donc on essaie de
faire un tour pour le voir en fait c'est
qui reste aujourd'hui c'est dont les
gens se souviennent à fait voici le
programme juste une question d'ordre
pratique il n'ya pas d'inscription pour
venir on peut venir directement aux
populations pour le musée on attend pour
le monde à partir de 11h et
tu as les deux événements à la fois le
marché
à fond moto et les expositions qui sont
on a là disons la mairie nous a mis à
disposition pour le complexe donc on a
les gymnases avec des escales de la
photo on a le boulodrome avec de marché
et les espaces de brno en extérieur avec
tous les autres espaces on pourra je
dirais
partager ensemble le repas qui seront
proposés dû discuter jouer
on attend tous merci d'être venu en
parler mais avec mac tango en plateau il
rappelle cette date du 8 mai avec
peut-être l'animation qui va pouvoir
s'afficher pour avoir toutes les
informations en journée de 8 mai journée
au pain qui aura lieu de 11h à 18h au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny-le-bretonneux toutes les
informations sur le site internet qui
s'est affichée merci encore d'avoir été
avec nous et en parlant dommage dimanche
ce sera aussi la commémoration du 8 mai
1945 date de la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale avec et des cérémonies
organisées dans toutes les communes pour
connaître le programme rendez-vous
directement sur le site internet de
votre mairie
bixente ma attentiste et bâle qui est
toujours avec moi aussi en plateau pour
la deuxième partie de cette émission
consacrée aux idées de sorties pour le
week-end idées de sorties et loisirs on
va commencer avec du vélo et vous avez
mouiller le maillot pour l'occasion ont
migré pour donner envie aux gens de
sortir il faut parfois savoir montrer
l'exemple en ce moment il ya une sorte
de challenge qui s'appelle le met à vélo
le but c'est de favoriser la pratique du
vélo en partenariat avec l'application g
au vélo il ya un classement des
communautés par exemple la communauté
yvelinoise avec environ 1200 inscrits
donc j'ai pris un vtt j'ai parcouru
quelques kilomètres pour vous faire
découvrir le département et contribue au
challenge regardez
le mode mais c'est souvent le retour du
beau temps c'est l'occasion de faire des
sorties en extérieur je vais en profiter
j'ai sorti mon petit vélo l'idée c'est
de vous faire découvrir un peu les
environs ou pas côté les 78 on va faire
un petit tour d'avoir jusqu'où ça
pénible et essayer de découvrir les
beaux paysages du département c'est
parti
mais
partant de guyancourt j'ai choisi une
boucle qui passe par le parc national de
la vallée de chevreuse dampierre en
yvelines connu pour son château jusqu'à
la destination finale la bt votre cerner
près de rome ou non
[Musique]
cinq minutes que je suis parti pour
l'instant on reste dans la ville bien
sûr mais toujours sur des pistes
cyclables donc c'est plutôt sécurisant
et il fait déjà chaud donc je me demande
si d'ici quelques minutes je vais pas
enlever beaucoup
[Musique]
le trajet me guider j'ai utilisé une
application mobile on rentre une
destination elles ne trouvent une voie
adaptée on peut choisir d'avoir un
chemin direct sécurisé touristique ou
bien équilibrée et le petit bonus pour
l'événement du mais à vélo on a un
classement départemental selon ces
kilomètres parcourus dans le monde
[Musique]
ensuite il pose ici parce que c'est
vraiment frappant l'espace de les 500 m
2 minutes on est passé de la ville à la
campagne la immenses étendues devant moi
donc c'est plutôt agréable
[Musique]
il
pour vient de faire une grosse décembre
forcément après tout descente regard
montée c'est parti on sait on à baisser
la vitesse c'est en a le temps de toute
façon
[Musique]
m
au monde
[Musique]
dans la descente que je viens de faire
elle est connue par les cyclistes du
coin c'est la descente des dix sept
tournant là j'arrive à dampierre en
yvelines c'est à peu près la moitié de
mon trajet aller donc on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire pendant les 7 km qui
nous reste
qui
[Musique]
voilà je suis arrivé à la bd vous de
cerner c'est la moitié de notre âge et
je vous fais pas de petites vies parce
qu'il est en rénovation en ce moment
nous ça nous fait en tout cas la moitié
du trajet on a 20 km ce qui fait qu'avec
le retour cela fera 40 km pour le met à
vélo de l'équipe des yvelines pour faire
un petit bilan de cette allée alors au
début dans les communes il y avait des
voix ou des pistes cyclables à chaque
fois donc c'était plutôt sécurisant
ensuite quand on arrive en réalité bien
sûr nice ont pu mais on est quand même
pas mal à distance avec les voitures le
petit bémol peut-être ces quelques
camions que j'ai croisés quand ils nous
dépasse à haute vitesse
c'est pas toujours très rassurant mais
ça fait partie du jeu faut être prudent
nous voilà on va faire tourner
tranquillement mais on va prendre notre
temps puisque l'important c'est pas
d'aller vite c'est de voir de beaux
paysages c'est de se faire plaisir aussi
[Musique]
souvenez-vous à l'aller je suis passé
par la mythique code des dix sept
tournant en descente au retour je dois
donc affronter son équivalent du côté du
mesnil-saint-denis ce ne sont pas les 17
mai les cette tournée
[Musique]
bon je suis à mi chemin du retour donc
j'en profite pour faire une petite pause
pour admirer un peu le paysage et après
on va repartir pour les dix derniers
kilomètres
[Musique]
pour finir ma boucle est rentré à vue en
cours mon chemin n'a conduit à travers
la verrière et rap c'est plusieurs bains
et moins adaptés aux vélos que ma
première partie de route et bien sûr
pour terminer toute épopée il fallait
forcément une petite averse heureusement
j'étais presque arrivé
voilà donc je suis bien revenu au point
de départ donc au total ça fait quarante
kilomètres à rythme léger l'important
quand on se lance de toute façon c'est
de choisir un trajet selon sa forme et
bien sûr les lieux qu'on souhaite
explorer il me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter bon courage pour ce mois de
mai un vélo et à bientôt
[Musique]
bravo à vous bixente en plus les
éléments n'ont pas forcément été à
l'égout à la fin ils appuient la
confiance que j'étais pas la rédaction
ou vendre votre retour vous étiez un peu
sur les rotules donc un peu fatigué j'ai
fait un bon trajet mais ça m'a permis de
me classer en tout cas je suis 126e sur
les 1100 je suis encore moins avec mes
40 km du premier qui lui est à 427 km
juin de regarder ou encore quelques
minutes d'efforts avant avant le
week-end pour vous bixente alors à faire
dès ce week end justement en plus il
fait très beau un pur pour cette idée de
sortie à vélo on se projette aussi sur
le week-end prochain à présent bixente
une idée de sortie cinéma en plus médine
yvelines cette idée oui dormez je le
veux c'est le nouveau et premier film de
la compagnie c'est net et sans bavure en
partenariat avec jolie prod l'équipe du
film sera en avant-première au cratère à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines samedi 14 mai
à 18 heures nous avons rencontré les
réalisateurs celle interview express
moment nous sommes florine et alex ans
on est les réalisateurs de dormez je le
veux le film qui sort le 14 mai en
avant-première au cratère de
saint-arnaud
à la base ce film c'est une pièce de
théâtre de georges feydeau qu'on a joué
très longtemps avec notre troupe de
théâtre c'est net et sans bavure on
était censé la jouer pour la deuxième
fois au festival d'avignon en 2020
festival qui a été annulé ben pour le co
lead et du coup un peu frustré tout ça
on a décidé d'en faire un film on s'est
dit pourquoi pas donc on sait associer
tous les deux autres comédiens de la
troupe alexandre guider et on a fait un
scénario pendant tout le temps du
confinement qu'on a écrit bien sûr on
skype à la fin du confinement le le film
est écrit est prêt à tourner et du coup
on a tourné en remplacement du festival
d'avignon en juillet 2001
l'histoire c'est justin c'est un valet
qui a des dons du pnns et qui s'en sert
pour faire faire toutes les tâches toute
la maison à son maître borique et donc
il coule la vie tranquille et paisible
sort guère aujourd'hui vas-y seulement
un jour doré qui décident de se marier
quand justin découvre ça il va tout
faire pour faire capoter le mariage
pouvoir garder pour toujours en fait
sont mettre à son service
on a vraiment hâte d'avoir le retour de
du public des gens qu'on connaît des
gens qu'on ne connaît pas le montant
positif négatif également mais surtout à
nous améliorer en tant que ben
en tout cas réalisateur de comédies
longtemps que cameramen tous péri
qui se transpose laisse syrienne
[Musique]
donc on peut aller au cinéma mais on
peut peut se passer aussi sa soirée du
14 mai au musée oui en effet puisque
avec une vingtaine de lieux culturels
dans les yvelines les idées de sorties
se multiplient à l'occasion de la future
nuit européenne des musées nous vous
proposons un top 5 des activités à faire
[Musique]
celle là
c'est le fan day
je ne
[Musique]
m
et d'autres idées de sorties bixente
pour clôturer cette émission avec un peu
de lecture oui le deuxième salon du
livre et de la bd de triel sur seine
aura lieu le 14 mai prochain au sein de
l'espace rémy barre à 34 auteurs seront
présents pour leurs travaux rencontrer
les lecteurs discuter avec eux sont
prévus des tables rondes des ateliers
créatifs une exposition de planches de
bd et des remises de prix littéraires
une belle journée donc pour remplir sa
table de nuit de nouveaux romans polars
ou encore bande dessinée on termine en
musique un festival à montigny le
bretonneux exactement gris breeze c'est
l'harmonie de saint quentin en yvelines
qui nous convient à son deuxième
festival d'harmonie ça va se dérouler
les samedi 14 et dimanche 15 mai au
programme une après-midi en extérieur le
samedi avec des concerts partout dans la
commune début à 15 heures dans trois
lieux différents le conservatoire des
arts le pavé du canal et la sourderie
mise en bouche donc pour se regrouper
tout le reste du week-end à la ferme du
man est le temps fort c'est bien sûr le
samedi à 20 heures 30 avec l'harmonie de
saint quentin en yvelines suivies de
l'harmonie de la musique de l'air enfin
le dimanche d'autres concerts auront
lieu dans cette même ferme du man est un
festival qui se clôturera à 17h par
l'orchestré départemental des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines pour toutes les
informations rendez vous sur le site
internet de la ville de montigny pour
réserver ce sera à la mairie ou bien via
la billetterie en ligne sur le site lots
asso.com merci bixente pour toutes ces
idées c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent tous les deux
dans deux semaines c'est ça pour les
actes à nouveau cette ut week-end qui
sera quand même au programme à le sais
tu ce week-end la semaine prochaine et
l'information locale elle revient elle
là dès lundi 18h avec le journal de la
rédaction d'ici là bien sûr passer un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]